i'd like to just spend a moment talking
about the
new variant so the new variant
and viruses mutate all the time but the
new variant contains
23 different changes
many of them associated with changes in
the protein that the virus makes
this is an unusually large number of
variants
it's also got variants in areas of the
virus
that are known to be associated with how
the virus binds to cells and enters
cells
so there are some changes which cause
concern
in terms of how the virus looks
but on top of that there are three
questions that need to be asked
does the tran vir does the new variant
transmit more readily i.e does it make
an increased chance of spreading growth
the second is does it alter the course
of the disease does it make people
sicker
and the third is does it alter the way
that the
immune system the way the body responds
to it if it's been previously infected
or following the vaccine i want to deal
with the first question
there are three different sources of
evidence from genetic studies
to frequency studies to laboratory
studies
all of which come together to suggest
this virus
has a significant substantial increase
in transmissibility
and this is also highlighted in this
graph which shows the proportion
of all the cases that were due to the
new variant
so the new variant was first thought to
have occurred sometime in mid-september
in london or kent and by the middle of
november
about 28 or so of the cases
in london and the southeast and slightly
lower in the east of england
were due to the new variant so it had
grown rapidly
by the week commencing the 9th of
december these figures were much higher
so in london over 60 percent of all the
cases were the new variant
so what this tells us is that this new
variant not only moves fast
it is increased in terms of its ability
to transmit
but it is becoming the dominant variant
it is beating all the others
in terms of transmission so this virus
transmits and spreads fast
does it alter the disease program
disease course
the answer seems to be no as far as we
can tell at the moment there's no
evidence
it causes a more severe disease causes
more hospitalization
causes more trouble than the other virus
so
it basically looks similar
does it alter the immune response or is
the immune response less able to
recognize it
there are theoretical reasons to suspect
that some of the changes
might alter some of the immune responses
but there's nothing that's been seen to
suggest that's the case
and our working assumption at the moment
from all the scientists
is that the vaccine response should be
adequate for this virus that's obviously
needs to be looked at going forward and
we need to keep vigilant about this
but the big change therefore is not
disease progress
not the immunity but transmission this
virus spreads more easily
and therefore more measures are needed
to keep it under control
we absolutely need to stick to the
basics
of making sure that we reduce our
contacts reduce the ability for this
virus to spread
and that's the reason that tougher
measures are required to keep this
variant under control